worshiping the sun worshiping the moon
worshiping the water mummification
cannibalism
[Music]
hi I'm Mariano hotter I'm a
anthropologist and archaeologist I
specialize in
ah do I specialize in anything that's a
I don't know what the second half of
that sentence was I'm not sure and the
thing I specialized in in my writing is
writing about British uh his uh
archeology particularly British
prehistory because I think it is amazing
it is so strange so varied so
not really what the world expects
because when they think about British
archeology they think of the Romans
probably a bit of you know castles you
know the crown
you know
palaces and historic properties well
they tend not to think about is all the
weird and wonderful stuff that you find
in prehistory the stuff where
it wasn't Britain back then of course
but
on this land that we find ourselves in
right now uh there were people
worshiping the sun worshiping the moon
worshiping the water there were people
practicing shamanic acts there were
people practicing the cannibalism there
were people practicing mummification and
we have sites and artifacts that can
take us back to those places take us
back to perhaps starting to explore some
of those themes perhaps some of those
connections that we might have now
but
modern archaeological science has
answered many questions for us it's
fantastic with terms of things like
radiocarbon dating with isotope analysis
which means that you can determine uh
where someone grew up or what they were
eating because you've analyzed the
particular version of the chemical in
their teeth or bones
but when you look at these complicated
slightly strange often multi-period so
used for a long period of time by
different people bringing their own
interpretations their own modifications
to these sites
what you're often left with despite the
Leaps and Bounds of archaeological
science is a kind of
what were they thinking why did they do
that how does this all make sense
because it's internally incoherent or
it's utterly baffling and secret Britain
is basically
um about 75 sites and artifacts that for
me made me go what
and I thought if that's the criteria
basically if I go what then it goes in
the book
I've got on my computer of volume two uh
of other sites and artifacts that maybe
go what but didn't make it into the
first one so the first one that I want
to start with because this is Whistle
Stop I had to pick a few uh because
otherwise we will be here till midnight
and they'd be booting us out or we'd be
bedding down either way
um this is Anglesey it's a site called
bring Kesley V which forgive my
pronunciation it's the mound in the dark
Grove nowadays it's the mound in a
farmer's field often you share it with
sheep often you share it with other
people coming to explore weird and
wonderful bits of British prehistory but
other than that there's very little
interpretation there's no souvenir
program there's no guidebook it's just
you walking through the field mind the
Sheep and oops bad language and
then here you come to what is actually
the back of a beautiful Mound the mound
and the stones around it were first
constructed around 3000 BC
so that makes it about 500 years earlier
than the stones the big trilathon Stones
being erected at Stonehenge this is the
Neolithic the late Stone Age so people
are farming
they have Pottery but they don't have
metal
so they're using Flint tools
um and then all the kind of organic
materials Timber and leather and hide
and
um plant-based textiles
bone all that stuff as well the weird
thing about this place is it's got
multiple
meanings and it's very very unique at
First Sight it's a chambered tomb so a
burial site it's got an entrance way
which is actually on the other side to
the angle that we're looking at from
there and as kind of a narrow passageway
you can go in and then when you kind of
enter into the kind of central chamber
hence chamber tomb that is where there
would have been human remains placed by
uh farming people from this area
probably
I say probably because people might have
come from a wider area to bring some of
their dead not everybody in a community
would have ended up in a chambered tomb
like this there's another one quite
close by which is quite close by not
really about as far away as Anglesey in
Wiltshire
West Kenneth Long Barrow some of you may
have uh heard of that or gone to visit
again not much signage you've got a park
upon the lay-by next to the a road climb
up the hill Dodge the cattle and and
then you get to commune with the
ancestors going into this portal you
kind of have to duck down there's a kind
of a physical experience of the the tomb
um which I think is really magical there
are no longer any human remains in there
they've been taken away actually in the
case of this one they were taken away
quite early on those antiquarians wanted
to do a bit of investigating so they
took them all away it was probably used
for about 50 to 60 maybe up to 100 years
so not that long given the amount of of
person hours using probably antler picks
to dig the Earth and make a mound and to
construct this Central chamber with big
stones
the thing about bring Kesley V though is
that it is um it's got more details to
it which make it
fit the criteria of what
the first thing is this standing stone
with this really intricate but slightly
crazy
pattern incised into the stone this is
actually
a replica the real one is in the
national museum
because the rain in Wales will
eventually wash away the pattern and it
was decided that we should probably keep
the pattern and also a pattern that we
can see so it's a replica but it's a
perfect replica
no one knows what this is the we've got
one other site near to bring cattley the
on Anglesey Island itself which is in
for those of you who don't know the top
North West corner of Wales uh just a
little distance from the um Mainland
we've got two examples of these
patterned stones at both nearby one here
bring Catholic and one uh just up the
road a place called barclayords
uh the only other places we see these in
Britain and Ireland were all the most of
the places we see are in Ireland so the
thinking is first of all maybe these
were Irish settlers again they didn't
think of themselves as Irish but forgive
me shorthand the people who were living
on the island of Ireland came over in a
boat and perhaps had a sort of an
outpost maybe they were setting up
um a settlement here uh found some space
a few people died the community lived
for a while or maybe there were Traders
and and people uh working with people in
Ireland they went the guys over the war
to do this really cool thing with stones
they do all sorts of interesting
patterns we should try that and someone
said yeah all right but we've only got
two examples so obviously didn't catch
on
no one knows what this is people have
said oh is it a star map that doesn't
really look like it is it some kind of
celestial Journey could be at this point
your guess is as good as any experts
because you can go to Anglesey and stare
at the stone and go I think it's a fill
in the Gap it's up to you because we
don't know what it is it's not a
physical representation of something in
the world it's not a kind of map of how
to get to Donald's house so we don't
know what it is
the other weird thing about this is that
it was never designed to be standing up
it was a decision made because
um after the mound was excavated uh this
was found lying down it was lying face
down with the pattern facing the ground
and then the first version of this mound
was much greater and it would have
covered
the pattern Stone
face down completely
so the first people to after the first
phase of construction would perhaps
never they would certainly have never
have seen it they might have known it
was there but they didn't you wouldn't
have known unless you knew as it were
so what does it mean did they ritually
kill the stone was it brought from
somewhere else and then buried was it
always intended to be buried maybe it
was laid flat facing down because it was
some kind of offering to some kind of
I'm gonna call them spirits of the earth
maybe that was a gift to them
because if you go inside
this is where you can walk in
it's all about light and darkness and
going underground so a burial chamber is
always that experience where you feel
like you're then in the Earth because
there's a mound of Earth above you a
Neolithic burial chamber not all of them
this is a really odd pillar of stone
again completely unique in Britain and
Ireland this passage into the into the
tomb is perfectly aligned for mid-summer
Sunrise which again is something that's
very familiar in tombs in Ireland like
somewhere like Newgrange there's one day
in the year coming up 21st of June you
could go and visit you won't be alone
that morning now I'll tell you that for
sure there'll be a bunch of other people
um a stream of light a beam of light
because of the Rising Sun penetrates the
team and uh shines onto the back wall
and if if you imagine the back wall here
on the other side of the back wall is
that pattern stone that would have been
in the earth so it would have Shone
towards the pattern stone is that
significant I don't know
that's my voice that's my noise
this weird smoothed pillar very rare
very odds
never ever gets lit by the sun it's just
out into the corner so it's always in
the darkness it's always in the shadow
even on a day that isn't mid-summer
the light doesn't reach it that's a
flash it's flash photography
is it phallic
is it a sort of a wood kind of thing
perhaps denoting something of the living
is it a guardian a kind of human figure
or a kind of sort of human sort of
spiritual representation
we don't know once again once you've
worked out the pattern Stone head on
inside and work out the pillar Stone
because you'll guess once again is as
good as the experts
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas